Ngày 2 mưa tháng 3, huy bán nhân dân cách mạng mặt bộ và hành động được thành lập giả mắt nhân dân.
Tháng lời tại Thú Đô đã tác động dây chuyển, thuốc đầy cáo chào cách mạng trên tòn quốc.
Tại thành quyền thử dạng sáng lức lượng dài phóng quân cùng nhân dân vào vầy thị sả,
bột tình trận và lính bảo an đầu hàng thu hàng trăm khổ xuống.
Bột trào mỹ tình lớn được tổ chức, chính quyền cách mạng giả mắt,
2 chí đội dài phóng quân và và bốn được thành lập.
Ở năm đi, huy bán khởi giữa được thành lập, nhàng trọng bột tình trường vài xác lục con sấu,
con tạng niên mình, hàng vạn quân trúng cùng các đội tự vẻ diễn vẻ tình lý,
dành chính quyền và tình.
Tháng quả thử thiên và nhiều tình chung nằm kỳ cũng đường loạt khởi giữa.
Châu tối ngày 2,5 năm, 1 in chính trọng bốn mấy lắm,
Việt Minh giá tôn khai tại xa con, chính bài chương trình hành động,
khu học quân trúng đứng lên dành lực lập giới cờ Việt Minh,
thế và lịch quốc cách mạng đã trở nên át đạo.